Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Tous les étés avec mes parents,
nous partions en camping.
Cette année-là, ils décidèrent de prendre
un camping avec animation.
Parce que bon, le camping sauvage,
c’est bien, mais à treize ans, c’est nul.
Les vacances se passent bien ;
je sympathise avec une fratrie.
On se retrouve à la table
de ping pong ou à la piscine.
Ce jour-là, on se retrouve à la piscine.
On s’amuse bien, certains sautent dans
l’eau, certains courent autour de l’eau.
Et alors que je marchais
le long de la piscine,
un des garçons de la fratrie
passe derrière moi
et me baisse ma culotte
de maillot de bain.
Je suis choquée,
surprise.
Je me retourne et je balance un :
« Mais ça ne va pas, non ! »
Il rigole.
Personne ne réagit.
Tout est normal.
Des enfants qui jouent entre eux.
Un peu plus tard,
alors que nous étions à table,
mon père me fit une remarque que j’ai
trouvée culpabilisante et accusatrice.
Il me dit :
« Juliette, je n’ai pas du tout aimé ce
qui s’est passé plus tôt à la piscine. »
Je vous avoue que je ne comprends
pas très bien sa remarque.
Croyait-il que ça m’avait plu, à moi ?
Mais si ça ne lui a pas plu,
pourquoi n’est-il pas allé voir le garçon
et lui dire que ce n’était pas bien ?
Peut-être que vous avez déjà vécu
une situation similaire ?
Ou se faire soulever
la jupe à l’école, mesdames ?
C’est normal,
des enfants qui jouent entre eux.
Normaliser le fait de se faire
soulever la jupe à l’école,
c’est ce que l’on appelle un script.
Des scripts, il en existe plusieurs.
Peut-être que parmi ceux
que je vais vous donner,
vous en avez déjà peut-être entendu.
« Ben, ne t’assois pas comme ça, voyons !
Tu es une fille, ce n’est pas approprié. »
« Ah les règles, c’est sale ! »
« Bon, un homme, ça a des besoins sexuels,
c’est comme ça. »
« Une femme ?
Comment est-ce que ça peut
être présidente ou juge ?
Parce que, à cause de ces règles, elle
n’est pas stable émotionnellement. »
Celle-ci, je l’ai entendue
il y a deux mois.
« De toute façon, le sexe, c’est simple.
C’est : pénétration et orgasme masculin
à la fin, rien de compliqué. »
« Oh, ça va, Les garçons
seront toujours des garçons. »
« Tu sais ma petite chérie,
tu ne devrais pas t’habiller comme ça.
Les garçons sont mal intentionnés.
Il va t’arriver des misères. »
La théorie des scripts a été développée
par des sociologues américains.
Elle décrit la façon
dont nos comportements sont dictés,
nous donnant une direction sur ce qui
est approprié, sur ce qui ne l’est pas.
Comment agir ? Comment répondre ?
Ces scripts sont applicables dans nombre
de domaines de la vie de la société,
tels que la sexualité par exemple.
Ces scripts nous permettent notamment
de comprendre pourquoi certaines choses
dans la société se répètent,
voire n’évoluent pas
aussi vite que l’on souhaiterait.
Parce que ces scripts, ces schémas, nous
les répétons sans nous en rendre compte.
Le problème est qu’ils peuvent
avoir de graves conséquences
sur la vie d’une femme
et sur son existence.
Je vais tenter aujourd’hui
de vous expliquer en quoi
ces scripts m’ont influencée et en quoi
ils nous influencent tous ou presque.
Nous sommes en 2008.
J'ai alors quinze ans.
Je sors avec un garçon
du même lycée que moi.
Il s’évertue rapidement à instaurer
un jeu des chatouilles,
jeu que je ne trouve pas
drôle du tout à l’époque,
parce qu’à chaque fois
qu’il commence à me chatouiller,
il glisse automatiquement
sa main dans ma culotte.
Je ne comprends pas pourquoi.
À chaque fois que je lui dis
d’arrêter, il rigole.
À chaque fois que je me débats,
il me bloque encore plus, rien n’y fait.
C’était ma première expérience sexuelle
et je ne comprenais pas à l’époque
la gravité de la situation.
Un mercredi, alors que
mes parents sont absents,
je me dis que ce serait plus sympa
de se voir à la maison
plutôt que dans la cour de récréation.
Alors je lui envoie un message
et je vous avoue que sa réponse
m’a un peu surprise :
« Tu sais que si je viens,
on va ‘le faire’. »
Euh...
(Tousse)
Je ne sais pas trop quoi répondre.
Je ne comprends toujours pas à l’époque
qu’il y a un gros problème
de consentement.
Et je réponds : « Euh ben j’ai peur,
mais euh, ok, viens. »
Il arrive et je n'ai rien
envie de faire du tout.
Il recommence son fameux jeu
des chatouilles
et je lui dis que j’ai trop peur,
que je ne veux rien faire.
Et là, à ma grande surprise,
il se met à bouder
et à me reprocher de ne rien
vouloir faire avec lui.
Parce qu’en plus, il m’avait prévenue.
Il savait
que je savais que s’il venait,
je savais ce qu’il se passerait.
Ben oui, c’est vrai, ce n’est pas faux,
il m’avait prévenue.
Ben oui.
Alors je me sens coupable.
Et au bout d'un moment,
je finis par céder.
Il commence.
Il me demande de le toucher,
mais je suis figée.
Je ne veux rien faire.
Alors il attrape ma main.
Je tremble.
Et il finit par me pénétrer.
Je ressens alors
une douleur terrible sur mon -
Je ressens alors une douleur terrible.
Je lui dis que j'ai mal.
Il continue.
Les larmes coulent sur le visage.
C'est un viol.
Mais pourquoi je n’ai pas réussi
à dire non ? Pourquoi ?
Pourquoi je ne l'ai pas repoussé ?
Pourquoi je ne l’ai pas envoyé balader ?
Pourquoi je ne l’ai pas quitté même ?
Cette question, elle s’est posée
pendant des années dans ma tête.
Pourquoi ?
J’avais reçu une éducation sexuelle,
j’ai une mère qui m’a toujours dit :
« Ton corps, c’est ton corps »,
qui a toujours ouvert la discussion.
Alors pourquoi ?
Ma réponse, je l’ai trouvée
dans la théorie des scripts.
Pour commencer, le script est genré,
c’est-à-dire qu’il est différent
pour les hommes et pour les femmes.
C’est comme si nous ne suivions pas
le même scénario en quelque sorte.
Un script,
c’est plus fort que l’éducation.
Ça englobe l’éducation,
mais ce sont aussi les messages diffusés
par la famille, l’école,
les médias, la publicité,
les films, les amis.
Et ces scripts engendrent des conséquences
socialement et sociétalement.
Il y a notamment un silence
sur le corps de la femme.
Une jeune fille n’est pas encouragée
à comprendre ni à découvrir son corps
et encore moins sa sexualité.
C’est plutôt tabou,
il ne faut pas en parler
alors qu’un garçon va être encouragé.
Peut-être de manière plus subliminale,
mais il va être encouragé
à découvrir son corps.
D’ailleurs,
un homme qui aime la sexualité,
c’est un Don Juan.
Une femme qui aime la sexualité,
c’est une nymphomane.
Certains scripts instaurent
une dynamique de soumission normalisée
entre l’homme et la femme.
En ne reprenant pas un garçon
qui soulève la jupe d’une fille,
ça va avoir des répercussions
conséquentes plus tard.
En ne disant rien, cela laisse entendre au
garçon que son comportement est normal
et qu'il a le droit de faire ce qu'il veut
avec le corps de quelqu'un d'autre.
À l’inverse, à la jeune fille,
ça lui diffuse le message
qu’elle doit se soumettre
et accepter ce qui est fait sur son corps
et que son non n’a aucune valeur.
À l’âge adulte, ça fait
qu’on se retrouve dans des situations
où l’homme ne comprend pas,
lorsqu’il s’avance vers une femme
pour danser,
pourquoi celle-ci le repousse.
Ce sont aussi des situations où l’homme
va se donner l’autorisation
de poser la main
sur la cuisse d’une femme.
Pourquoi pas de la chatouiller
un peu comme si de rien n’était ?
Et c'est presque normal.
C’est une conséquence, en tout cas,
très logique de ce script.
Si on reprend maintenant
le jeune garçon de mon histoire,
il a reçu ses autorisations.
Pour lui, ses actions sont donc
complètement normales.
Il n'y a aucun problème
dans son comportement.
Il a reçu ses scripts.
Je suis d’ailleurs encore
persuadée aujourd’hui
qu’il n’a aucune idée de ce qu’il m’a fait
et que pour lui, ce n’était pas un viol.
En effet.
Alors que 37% des femmes
déclarent avoir déjà vécu
une situation de non-consentement,
seuls 12% des hommes
affirment avoir déjà forcé leur partenaire
à avoir un rapport sexuel.
Je ne suis pas très bonne en maths,
mais pour moi, il y a un problème.
Et 41% des hommes de 18 à 24 ans pensent
que forcer sa partenaire à avoir un
rapport sexuel alors que celle ci-refuse
n’est pas un viol.
Et si, du coup,
on donnait l’autorisation aux femmes
de baisser le pantalon des garçons ?
C’est peut-être la solution, non ?
Non.
Pour moi, ce n'est pas la solution.
Aucune des deux situations
ne devrait être autorisée.
Et pourtant, se sentant
démunie face au script,
c’est ce que ma mère a fait.
J'étais à l'école primaire.
Un garçon s’amusait régulièrement
à soulever la jupe des filles,
la mienne y compris.
En ayant marre,
je suis allée le voir et lui en parler.
Un jour, alors que celle-ci
venait me chercher à l’école,
elle me demanda de lui montrer
qui était l’auteur de ce fameux jeu.
Elle s’avança alors
vers la mère du garçon -
moi, cachée derrière ses jambes, je vous
avoue que je n’étais pas très rassurée.
Elle s’adressa à la mère du garçon,
lui demandant si elle pouvait
s’adresser au garçon.
Elle lui dit :
« Bonjour, moi,
je suis la maman de Juliette.
Il paraît que c’est toi qui t’amuses
à soulever la jupe des filles à l’école ?
Si tu continues, voilà ce qu’on va faire.
Je vais donner l’autorisation de baisser
ton pantalon devant tout le monde. »
Est-ce qu’on est obligé d’en arriver là ?
Est-ce qu’on ne peut pas faire quelque
chose avant d’en arriver là ?
Moi, j’en suis persuadée,
qu’on peut faire quelque chose.
Mais c’est de notre responsabilité à tous,
ici, dans cette salle,
en dehors de cette salle.
Maintenant que vous connaissez
ces scripts,
que vous avez pris conscience
de ces scripts,
lorsque vous voyez des situations
où ces scripts sont répétés,
donnés,
intervenez et expliquez.
Ça changerait l'existence
de beaucoup de femmes.
À nous de jouer.
(Applaudissements)